this video is sponsored by skillshare hi
it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd
and not a big fan of the idea that you
have to be rich to afford
good skin care products there is a lot
of misinformation
about medical grade or clinical or
professional skincare products online
you might have heard that these premium
price products that you can usually only
get from dermatologists or skin clinics
are guaranteed to be more effective or
better or less toxic
than drugstore or so-called
over-the-counter otc
products that you can get from the
supermarket and from the pharmacy
you might have heard that non-medical
grade products don't provide benefits to
your skin
or they're completely useless or they
might even destroy your skin this
is pretty confusing because a lot of
dermatologists do recommend
cheap easily available brands that you
can get at the drugstore
at the supermarket like cetaphil and
cerave
so what's going on here let's talk about
medical grade skin care
if you like noting out about the science
behind beauty products click the like
the subscribe
and the notification bell so you don't
miss any videos
[Music]
firstly let's clarify we're talking
about products that are sold at these
places for you to take home and use
we're not talking about things like
pills that only trained people can use
on you while you're at the clinic
we're talking about the products that
are like cleansers or serums or toners
or moisturizers
that are so called medical grade or
clinical
medical grade skin care products are
regulated differently
the first claim is that medical grade
skin care is regulated differently by
the fda
or whatever relevant authority there is
in your particular country
this isn't true in the us the vast
majority of skin care products are
regulated as cosmetics
and so that means they don't need any
sort of regulatory approval
or proof of effectiveness before they
get launched and you can buy them
that doesn't mean that they're not
regulated so they still have to be safe
they can't contain
banned ingredients and they still have
to be stable and uncontaminated
this is the case in most places around
the world and this applies to
medical grade skin care and drugstore
skin care products
there's no legal difference between the
two categories on the other hand we have
drugs and when it comes to skin care
products this is over-the-counter drugs
or prescription drugs i think a lot of
the confusion comes from the use of the
phrase
over-the-counter people promoting
medical grade skin care products often
use this term to describe
products that you buy at the drugstore
and they say that
over-the-counter products are less
effective than medical grade products
in drug regulation over-the-counter has
a legal meaning
it refers to drugs that you can buy
without a prescription
and so over-the-counter drugs are
actually more strictly regulated than
most medical grade skin care
over-the-counter drugs include things
like sunscreen
aspirin benzoyl peroxide cream and
antihistamines
this is in contrast to a prescription
drug where you need to have a
prescription from an appropriately
authorized health professional
like a doctor before you're allowed to
buy it both over-the-counter drugs and
prescription drugs need to be approved
before they're allowed to be sold
and part of that approval process is
showing that it is effective
there are also different standards for
how drugs need to be manufactured
compared to cosmetics
products that are regulated as drugs
will be clearly labeled so in the us for
example there's the drug facts panel
in australia there will be the ost r or
the host l number
as well as the concentrations of the
active ingredients on the front
in some countries like japan and korea
there's also the quasi-drug or
cosmeceutical category
and that's also regulated a bit
differently from both drugs and
cosmetics but again that will also be
clearly labeled
but with medical grade products unless
they are actually a drug
there's no legal requirement for that
sort of labeling certain legal terms
there's no difference between medical
grade and
regular skin care products both can be
regulated as cosmetics or drugs
usually there's actually less drugs in
medical grade skin care than you can get
at a drugstore
so over-the-counter skin care drugs
include things like sunscreen benzoyl
peroxide creams adaptolene
salicylic acid and you can find most of
these in both medical grade and
regular skincare lines but the majority
of medical grade skin care products
are cosmetics and that means they're
less regulated in terms of their
efficacy
than over-the-counter drug skin care
products if you want to go straight for
the most effective stuff you can get
prescription only to zaritine and
tretinoin
creams and you won't find these in
medical grade skin care lines
you get these literally at the drugstore
there's rigorous testing and research
behind medical grade skin care products
they use
higher quality ingredients then there's
a myth that there's always rigorous
research and testing that goes into
making medical grade skin care products
but not
normal skin care products and the idea
that they use higher grade ingredients
but medical grade professional and
clinical aren't regulated terms and so
there is zero guarantee of this
some medical grade brands will do
rigorous testing and clinical studies
but anyone can slap the words medical
grade on their products and decide to
only sell through skin clinics
and there are lots of regular drugstore
skin care products that have rigorous
testing and clinical studies as well
some of the ones that are regulated as
drugs like sunscreen will have to go
through mandatory clinical studies
a lot of the more dermatologist-friendly
brands like cerave qv and bioderma
will have done lots and lots of clinical
studies on their products as well
even the really large mass market brands
that a lot of people promoting medical
grade products tend to diss
like olay and neutrogena they conduct a
lot of clinical studies and scientific
research that goes into making their
products
elay are responsible for a lot of the
information we know about niacinamide in
skin care neutrogena do a lot of studies
on sunscreens
and both of these brands publish a lot
of their research in leading
peer-reviewed scientific journals
on the other hand it's really rare that
you see a medical grade skincare brand
publish peer-reviewed scientific
research
they contain higher percentages of
actives they're allowed to penetrate
deeper than over-the-counter and
drugstore products
there are also these myths about the
effectiveness of the products
so medical grade skin care products are
supposedly allowed to put in higher
concentrations of actives
or they're allowed to penetrate deeper
into the skin and so the deeper it goes
the bigger the effect it can have
but again this is a myth because medical
grade has no legal meaning
so there's no regulatory difference and
so there's nothing that they are allowed
to do that regular skin care isn't
allowed to do
you can get really high percentages of
actors from brands like paula's choice
in the ordinary
and these are definitely not medical
grade skincare i think the myth
of medical grade skin care products
being the one true skincare that we
should all be using
is mostly perpetuated by people who have
good intentions
but they've been fed the wrong
information by brands who are either
being dishonest
or should really know better and that's
okay we've all fallen for marketing
myths before they can be really
convincing especially if they're coming
from someone who appears to be really
authoritative and knowledgeable but
there's also a small but very vocal
group of people online who are using
these myths
to bully and shame people they're
shaming people for not being rich enough
to be able to afford these products or
not wanting to spend more on these
products
because supposedly they don't care about
their skin enough
they're bullying people for being so
stupid to think that drugstore products
can actually work
and they're fearmongering about
drugstore products ruining people's skin
a lot of the time these people are also
selling medical grade skincare products
and all of this is really not okay i'm
not saying that medical grade products
are bad or they're not worth the price
a lot of them are really good and a lot
of clinical brands do invest in research
and hiring scientists
who can make their formulations really
effective ultraceuticals is one of my
favorite skincare brands because they
put a lot of effort into
making their products really effective
and they're in the clinical category but
that's not the case with all medical
grade skin care brands and there are
a lot of drugstore brands that also take
this sort of approach
medical grade skincare is just like any
other type of skin care whether it's
good or effective or worth the price
or if they have clinical studies to back
up their effects has to be
judged on a brand by brand or a product
by product basis
there are plenty of drugstore products
that work really well
and so you can build an effective
skincare routine on a budget
you can also build an effective routine
with more expensive medical grade
products
so it's perfectly fine to use and
promote medical grade skincare products
it's not okay to promote them using
myths
or to harass people who aren't using
these products
and if you sell medical grade skincare
products you shouldn't be using these
myths to promote your products anyway
deceptive marketing is illegal and
people who have been deceived
tend not to be very happy about it
afterwards if a product is honestly
amazing
you don't have to puff it up with myths
about fda regulation
or how deep they can go into your skin
or how toxic
drugstore products are if a product has
completely transformed your skin or
transformed your client's skin
then just say that that on its own is
very convincing marketing
if there's an amazing team of
researchers and formulators who have
contributed to making this product
if there are really good before and
after photos if it has
actives that you rarely find in other
products then again just say those
things
so those are my thoughts on medical
grade skin care do you use medical grade
skin care have you also seen these myths
floating around
let me know in the comments and if
there's a myth i've missed out on thanks
to today's video sponsor skillshare
they sponsor a lot of educational
content on youtube skillshare is an
online community that has thousands of
classes on a huge range of topics like
design
web development marketing and analytics
i take all of my instagram photos on my
phone and i recently switched from
android to
iphone and so i've had to re-learn a lot
of my processes
so i decided to go and properly learn
how to do phone photography
the class i took was iphone photography
how to take pro photos on your iphone by
dale mcmanus this actually isn't just
specific to iphones dell goes through
photo composition and the most useful
thing i found was learning how to use
the free version
of lightroom in the past i was uploading
my photos from my phone onto my laptop
so i could edit it with photoshop
and then re-download them back onto my
phone to post
and so it was really cool to learn how
to use a few extra features on my phone
so i could skip all that transferring if
you want to check out skillshare
the first thousand people to click the
link in the description we'll get a free
trial of the premium membership for a
limited time
it's normally less than 10 a month with
a yearly subscription
i hope you liked this video if you did
you can click the like and the subscribe
you can also follow me on instagram at
lab muffin beauty science and check out
my blog for more
sciencey nerdy beauty talk see you next
time